Man, monster, myth — Count Dracula is all
of these things and more.
But who is the man behind the fangs in The
Last Voyage of the Demeter?
There have been a lot of live-action versions
of Dracula over the years, but few of them
are as outright monstrous as the creature
featured in 2023's The Last Voyage of the Demeter.
This version of the classic vampire is an
absolute horror to behold, with bat-like wings,
elongated ears, and a mouth full of razor
sharp teeth.
"Satan's black blood pumping corruption through
his veins.
God's anger has come upon this vessel like
Jonah!"
"Shut up!"
It's such a ghoulish, inhuman rendition of
the character, in fact, that it may be easy
for audiences to forget that there's an actor
under all that prosthetic makeup.
The Dracula featured in The Last Voyage of
the Demeter is played by none other than Javier
Botet, and the drastic difference in appearance
between the real-life actor and his on-screen
persona may prove shocking to some viewers.
If Botet's name sounds familiar, it's probably
because the performer has been routinely involved
in major horror films for well over 15 years
— and in most cases, he's playing something spooky.
For the bulk of his career in film and television,
Javier Botet has worked as a specialized type
of actor known as a creature performer.
As the name implies, that means he more often
than not portrays inhuman or monstrous characters
that require a lot of preparation by way of
prosthetics and makeup.
In addition to Dracula, Botet has played some
of the most terrifying horror movie villains out there.
He appeared as the Crooked Man in The Conjuring
2, a Xenomorph in Alien: Covenant, various
forms of It in It and It Chapter Two, and
Slender Man in Slender Man — to name but a few.
Suffice to say, he knows his way around horror.
Interestingly enough, Botet has the unique
capacity to physically manipulate his body
— something which he uses to great effect
in his roles.
In an interview with the BBC, he said:
"I have a disease called Marfan syndrome.
It makes people skinnier, taller, and very
flexible.
So I was all my life very flexible, all my
life doing weird tricks and things to enjoy
with my friends [using] very creepy movement."
While many of Botet's biggest roles are scare-filled
creature flicks, he has also amassed credits
in non-horror productions — some of which
have him in prosthetics, while others don't.
Recent years have also seen him cross over
to mainstream sci-fi and fantasy franchises,
appearing as an undead wight in Game of Thrones
and one of the alien Ba'ul in Star Trek Discovery.
While Botet has played a cavalcade of mainstay
monsters in his time, he had long awaited
the opportunity to sink his teeth into the
role of Dracula.
The actor did once play the character all
the way back in a 2007 episode of the Spanish
series Los hombres de Paco, but he wanted
nothing more than to bring the horror icon
to life in a full-fledged monster movie.
Last Voyage of the Demeter turned out to be
his big shot.
In an interview with Screen Rant, Botet spoke
about getting cast as Dracula, as well as
reuniting with director André Øvredal on
Last Voyage of the Demeter.
He said:
"For me, it would be an honor, and finally
it happened.
It was great to know that André Øvredal
was directing, because after a lot of projects,
you need to meet a lot of new people, it's
fine, but always when you are going to need
a big crew, when you've worked already with
somebody, it's easier, it helps.
I remember it was so easy, and so nice."
Botet particularly relished the chance to
portray Øvredal's unique take on Dracula
— a brutal, animalistic being who transforms
from a weakened wretch to a terrifyingly powerful
force of darkness.
As he says:
"Our Dracula was not a classical, sexy guy,
so for me, it was good to try something different,
something more heavy."